- Hi everyone, welcome to
our Homeroom live stream.
I'm very excited about the conversation
we're going to have in a few minutes.
But before that, I will give
my standard announcement,
a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization
with a mission of providing
free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere,
and we only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So, if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
I wanna give a special shout-out
to several corporations
that have stepped up
when they appreciated that Khan Academy
was running at a deficit
even before the COVID crisis,
and our costs only went
up, our server costs,
we wanted to accelerate a
whole series of programs,
and so they've helped
us close our deficit.
We still have one, so
we still need your help,
but it's been a huge support.
Novartis, who we're gonna talk
to Vas Narasimhan in a few seconds,
is one of those supporters.
Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, and Fastly.
So, thanks to all of them,
and our many other philanthropic
and corporate supporters,
and any of you who have donated
or even thought about donating.
So with that, I'm very excited
to introduce Vas Narasimhan.
Vas, good to be here, or
thanks for having you (laughs).
- Great to be here Sal,
it's really an honor.
I think, as you know, my family
has used Kahn Academy for years,
it's a huge part of our
family in many ways,
and we're honored as Novartis
to be able to support your efforts.
- No, no, well, and we're honored
that y'all are working with this.
It was funny, when I was doing
what light research I do before this,
I realized that we are the exact same age,
and that created a bit of
an existential moment in me,
because you run a large, multinational,
like 100,000-plus person organization,
and you know, I hang out in a
walk-in closet making videos,
so it kind a made me ponder my life.
- But no, not at all, you've touched
hundreds of millions of
children all around the world,
it's extraordinary work.
- But, I'd love to hear,
one of the things that we like to do,
and I encourage anyone who's
watching on YouTube or Facebook
to start asking questions,
about really anything,
but I think what I like to do here,
especially because there's a
lot of young people watching,
is just understand, how do you become,
well first, what does Novartis do?
I think many people know
it's one of the largest
pharmaceutical companies in the world,
but also, and what's it focus,
but also, I'd like to understand
how you ended up here.
So maybe just start with,
just make sure everyone understands
what Novartis does, and what its focus is,
and then I'd love to go
into your background.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, Novartis is about
a 250 year old company,
beginning in the world of
dye-making in the 1700s,
chemicals in the 1800s,
pharmaceuticals in the 1900s.
Today, we're one of the 50
largest companies in the world,
one of the two or three
largest makers of medicines in the world.
We make about, on the order of 800,
we reach about 800 million patients a year
with our medicines,
we produce about 70 billion
doses a year of medicine
in about 150 countries.
Everything ranging from medicines
to tackle heart disease,
and lung disease, and cancer,
all the way to malaria,
and leprosy medicine.
But also, very high-end
technologies like gene therapies,
and cell therapies.
We're also the second largest manufacturer
of generic medicines in the world.
So, a big goal to impact public health,
and as a public health physician,
it's really a dream job
to have this opportunity.
As for myself, my parents
were Indian immigrants,
they came to the U.S. in the
late '60s and the early 1970s.
I grew up in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
where I went to wonderful
public schools there,
and then later in southern New Jersey,
and so very grateful for
the incredible education,
and very dedicated,
amazing parents that I had.
I went to the University of
Chicago, studied biology,
went to Harvard Medical
School, studied medicine.
Did a lot of work in developing countries.
My passion for public
health was in Africa,
working in Africa, but
also in Peru, India,
and a few other locations.
But through kind of twists and turns,
I ended up wanting to pursue
the private sector approach
to impacting health on a global scale.
Was very interested in the science
of developing drugs and medicines,
and how that could have a big impact.
And so, I came to Novartis in 2005,
spent most of my career
developing vaccines and drugs.
I'm a member of the
National Academy of Medicine
in the United States because
of the work I've done
developing drugs and vaccines.
And that led, from one thing or another,
to me somehow being the
CEO of this company,
as a physician/scientist who
always just had a big dream
to impact the public health of the world.
- Thanks for that, and
there's a lot there.
I'm assuming most people
have heard of Novartis,
but just the numbers that you just said
were kind of mind-boggling.
I mean, it's probably safe to say, maybe,
everyone watching, or at
least a close relative
of everyone watching is probably,
in some way, shape, or form,
taking some kind of medication,
hopefully being helped
by some type of medication
that's a Novartis drug.
So, that's incredible, incredible reach.
One question, actually, there's
a question from YouTube,
Annam Khan, no relation,
as far as I'm aware,
"How did you know what path
and what career was best for you?
How did you know it was your passion?"
Because you started as a,
you went to medical school,
you are a physician.
Did at some point it switch,
at first you thought you were going to be
a practicing physician,
but then you thought,
"Hey, what if I could help develop drugs,
or help scale therapies, whatever?"
- I think my mother is still wondering
when I'll become a cardiologist,
but I think she's generally
has moved on from that discussion.
Yeah, I don't exactly know.
People often ask me, and
I actually just completed
reading a great book by
David Epstein called "Range,"
and it talks about how, in the end,
building broad ranges of experience
will allow you to discover
where your best fit is.
So I think probably for ten years,
I did my medical studies,
I had every intention
of becoming a physician,
I worked at the World Health Organization,
worked quite a bit in
public health in Africa,
some great leaders.
Took a plunge into the private sector
without knowing where it would go.
I would say there were
many twists and turns,
and many moments I would have thought
this was not a good decision.
But then, I ended up, actually,
in the world of vaccines,
and I loved vaccines,
I loved developing new
vaccines for children.
Again, had the opportunity
to work with a number of
extraordinary vaccines,
and again, one thing led to another.
I think, the book talks about it,
I think it's worth remembering
in the world of education,
we wanna build broad minds,
because the world is complex,
and I think building
more range in yourself,
from the disciplines you learn,
how you can solve problems,
how you can think,
is what will ultimately
make you successful,
and I think Khan Academy
builds that in people.
- And of course, you know,
there's a kind of, I guess, a very blunt,
or funny version of the
question I was going to ask,
that someone at YouTube, AZ, asked,
when he said, how did you
take over the company,
which I don't think you perceived
your job as (indistinct).
But I guess, I'll take a
different version of it.
What do you think, you know,
when I was a kid, and
saw someone become a CEO
of a multinational
organization like Novartis,
and I'd be like, "How did they do that?"
There's a lot of smart
people in the world,
there's hundreds of thousands, and yeah,
I think at Novartis, you have
100,000-something employees,
what do you think it was about you,
and either it was opportunities you got,
serendipity, and things
that you actively did
that kind of got you on that path?
- Yeah, I'd say a couple things.
I give tremendous credit
to my parents, and my wife,
the three of whom without which
I certainly would not
be here at this moment.
But I think it was a mixture
of being able to understand
the science of medicines,
and having a deep understanding
of human biology and science,
combined with having learned
how to translate that
into business, and
numbers, and financials,
and how does that translate into business,
and really be able to
speak multiple languages,
speak the language of science,
and speak the language of business.
But I think that the third element in it,
it came back to my education
at the University of Chicago,
where I was educated in the great books,
was a kind of a deep understanding
of purpose, and values,
and mission, and trying to
instill in an organization,
and I think that combination.
I knew when I was named CEO,
I was not the traditional choice.
I think our board took a huge chance
in making me a CEO.
There was a lot more traditional
choices one could take
than taking a physician/scientist
who mostly worked on
developing drugs and vaccines.
If I'm not mistaken, I'm only one
of maybe a handful in the whole
biopharmaceutical industry
who comes from more the R&D background.
But I think it was that mix,
and having that ability
to cross those different disciplines,
and having a very humanitarian
approach, or view,
and we have a long journey to get there
to actually realize that,
but that was, I think,
the kind of key elements.
- Yeah, and given,
obviously, Novartis itself,
a major pharmaceutical company,
but your background as a physician,
you've helped develop vaccines.
The obvious questions, you could imagine,
a lot of questions coming in
on social media about that.
Judy Lenahan, "When will a vaccine
for COVID-19 become available,
and what unanticipated
roadblocks might delay it?"
And then Muran Ararat
from Facebook is asking,
"If and when it gets developed,
how long does it take for mass
production and availability?"
What's your view on that?
I don't know if Novartis is
explicitly doing activity there,
but I'm sure you also have a general view
of what's going on in the ecosystem.
- Yeah, you know, I spent nine years,
eight, nine years developing vaccines,
and working hard in that space.
We ultimately sold our vaccines business,
so we're not in the world
of vaccines right now,
but I can offer the perspective
more of somebody who knows
the space extremely well.
I think it's very important to understand
what it takes to develop a vaccine,
and how different a
vaccine is from a drug.
In the case of a drug, we
know a patient has a disease,
and we're treating the disease
so the so-called risk-benefit equation
is highly favored towards the drug,
because we know the patient is ill.
In the case of a vaccine,
we're immunizing somebody
who is otherwise healthy,
so the bar for safety is extremely high,
and the bar for what the
benefit of the vaccine is
is also extremely high.
The FDA recently put out guidance
which actually was very much
in line with what I expected.
The FDA said they expect studies
to be very large and well-controlled,
and said that studies should likely have
thousands, if not tens
of thousands of patients.
They expected a vaccine to
have 50% efficacy at least,
and they expected, at minimum,
six months of follow up
for the patients who are in the trial,
and longer if there was potentially
a new technology that's being used.
All of that comes together,
and I've been one of the people
who consistently have said,
that, being realistic,
given that any drug you
put into the clinic,
any vaccine you put in the clinic,
has somewhere between a one,
and at best case, 10% chance of making it.
So if we put in 100, we
probably will get one.
If we really understand what
we're doing, if we put in ten,
we'll get one really
effective vaccine or drug.
That's just the historical
odds in our sector.
And then you combine that
with what the FDA just talked abut,
I think it's realistic to expect
a broadly-available vaccine
not before towards the
latter part of next year.
Now, could there be an upside case,
could everything work perfectly?
Of course, and I understand
that's a lot of where the discussion is.
But it's important, also, to understand
why we want a very safe vaccine,
and why it's so important, in my mind,
to maintain the public trust.
Probably over the last 100 years,
vaccines, sanitation, and
a handful of medicines
have led to the remarkable
gains in life expectancy,
where people, on average, in 1900,
lived to about 30 years of age,
and today, depending on
where you are in the world,
80 to 90 years of age.
And what we don't wanna do
is undermine that belief in vaccines,
that's so fundamentally important
for our public health system.
- And there's several really
powerful things you said.
I mean, one, I thought that
was a really interesting way
to compare normal pharmaceutical
drugs with a vaccine.
As you mentioned, for
regular drug development,
someone has a disease, maybe
a really serious disease,
so you know they have it,
and so you just have to see, hey,
is the benefit of the drug,
probablistically, better
than the side effects, or the risk.
But a vaccine is a healthy person,
and the side effects and the negatives,
these things, you have to
look over thousands of people,
because even a small
negative is not so good,
because you're giving
it to healthy people.
And you also said, the expectation
is probably end of next calendar year,
so end of 2021 is your best guess?
- It's my guess, it's
just one person's guess.
As you know, there are a
lot of opinions out there.
But I think that would be remarkable,
to have a brand new virus show up,
and to have a vaccine out
the door within two years,
is frankly unprecedented,
and it would not have happened,
as far as I know, before.
In most cases, in pandemics,
we've generally had influenza pandemics,
so we've known how to
manufacture influenza vaccines
since about the 1950s,
at scale, very established technology.
The only thing we're changing
is the type of virus,
we're not changing the
manufacturing platform,
we're not changing the nature
of the immune response.
Now with COVID, we don't know
what kind of immune response we need,
we're trying to use very
new technology platforms
that have never been
used in a large scale,
to navigate all that
complexity within two years
would be pretty remarkable.
- So you're saying it's kind
of a fairly bullish prediction
to get end of,
because at least when you watch the news,
and even if you hear
governments around the world,
it seems like people are
hopeful for three months,
or four months, or by January,
but it sounds like we should
probably set our expectations,
it would be a good outcome
if we have a vaccine
by November, December of 2021.
- I would say yes, I think,
but that's not necessarily,
understandably,
what people are hearing.
I understand why there's hope,
and perhaps you could find a vaccine
that you could use with
certain populations,
first responders, faster,
but it's important to
understand what's required
from the data, and the science.
And the science and the
data have to demonstrate,
you're not gonna cause harm
to people who receive the vaccine,
and you need to have a reasonable
belief of strong efficacy.
I spent a lot of time
developing pediatric vaccines,
as a simple thing like a
high fever, as an example.
If you have a high fever,
in some significant rate,
in 20%, 30% of children
who receive your vaccine,
and if you give that
vaccine to tens of millions
or hundreds of millions of people,
you suddenly have lots of people
showing up in the emergency room
with fever related to the vaccine,
which then leads to
all other adverse
consequences for the system.
So it's important when we ensure
that we have a vaccine
we really believe in,
from an efficacy and safety standpoint.
And I think experts in vaccines
probably generally have
that kind of perspective.
- And just to make sure
everyone's on the same page,
the whole principle of immunization
is to inject something into your system
that you can build your
own immune response
so that if the real thing shows up,
so to speak, it's ready.
And there's these notions of antibodies,
which students can learn
about on Khan Academy,
which are kind of like tags,
or certain foreign substances
that your body doesn't want.
And once things are tagged,
then your immune system can
go and clean up that stuff,
kill that stuff.
And so you want those
tags, those antibodies.
How is a vaccine developed?
Is it essentially, do you get antibodies,
do you observe antibodies in people
who already have the
virus, you know, COVID,
and you take some of those,
do you just inject them in someone else?
Do you kind of denature them a little bit,
but the proteins are still there?
How does that work?
- So the few things you can do.
What you just referred to, Sal,
is so-called convalescent (indistinct).
These are patients who
have had the disease,
develop antibodies,
you take the antibodies
from those patients,
you give it to patients affected by COVID,
and you hope that transferring
the antibodies can help.
There've been mixed
results so far with that,
there's a lot of complexity
in really ensuring you have an adequate
so-called dose of the antibody.
So we'll have to see if that bears out,
but that's of course
not a scalable solution.
So then the question is, how do you give
components of the coronavirus,
COVID-19, to a human,
to generate a very robust immune response?
An immune response that
has a few characteristics.
One, that it has a high
enough level of antibodies,
as you've mentioned,
that can prevent, hopefully,
the disease from taking hold in a person,
and hopefully also elicit
what's called immune memory.
So immune memory is, the
immune system has the ability
to store cells, memory T-cells,
which can then come back if
the infection were to happen
at a later point in time.
This allows for the vaccine to protect
over a long period of time.
Now, right now there's a number
of different vaccine technologies
that are being used to
try to solve this problem.
One is giving RNA, and so
for the students listening,
you know DNA goes to RNA goes to protein.
So the idea here is if
you give patients RNA,
the cells in the body will turn that RNA
into the COVID surface proteins,
so one of the proteins on
the surface of the virus,
and then an immune response will develop.
Other approaches use DNA,
and the similar sort of idea,
can you get the cells to
produce the COVID particle.
The reason DNA and RNA are the
first vaccines in the clinic
is they're much easier to do
than isolating the actual
parts of the virus,
so you have DNA and RNA vaccines.
Another approach, used
by Oxford University,
is to actually have what's
called an attenuated virus,
in this case, the monkey adenovirus.
You weaken that virus
so that it doesn't cause
infection in humans, no illness,
but instead, that virus
is going to express
portions of the COVID-19 virus,
and again, you hope to
create the immune response.
So that's a attenuated
virus-based approach.
And then, I'm trying to simplify
probably a very complex field,
the other is a so-called subunit virus,
where you actually take
the proteins from COVID-19,
so you take the surface proteins,
and you combine it with
another thing called adjuvant,
which really boosts immune response,
and you hope that will elicit
a strong immune response.
The subunit-based approach
is largely what we have
for many of the vaccines
people are used to getting,
or the attenuated virus-based approach.
Other approaches are you could try
to weaken the COVID-19
virus itself and provide it,
and so all of these different
things are being approached,
but the idea of can we
elicit a high antibody titer,
can we create memory, and importantly,
can we do this in a very,
very, very safe way.
- Right, and make sure I understand.
So, at the end of the day,
you wanna have, essentially,
a low-risk version, or
cousin version of the virus,
or a piece of the virus,
essentially, of a protein,
that your immune system can then
learn to recognize with antibodies,
and the memory T-cells, and all the rest.
And, you can do that by,
I mean, you wouldn't insert
an entire RNA of COVID, would you?
Or would it be part of the RNA
that would produce some of the proteins?
- Yes, so we only typically
insert part of the RNA,
usually a coding RNA
for one of the proteins.
It turns out, once RNA
gets beyond a certain size,
it's very hard to give it in the body,
and have it be stable long enough
to get to the various cells.
- And, what's kind of the worst case?
I mean, not to scare folks,
and I know this isn't
the focus of Novartis,
but you can imagine,
there's a ton of questions
that are coming in
for how long you think this will last.
Alina on YouTube was asking, I mean,
I'm just curious, your views.
- Well, I think from
a broader perspective,
what's been remarkable to me
is the scale of the medical response.
When you look at it right now,
we have close to 500 vaccines
and drugs in assessment,
I think close to 5000 clinical trials
in one stage or another,
over 10,000 publications.
So just like we saw an
exponential increase in the virus,
we've seen an exponential
increase in the response.
We already know, and I
think it's underestimated,
how remarkable it is,
we've already discovered
one drug, called Remdesivir,
which is an antiviral drug,
one steroid that the
U.K. has now identified
that already can improve
patients course with coronavirus.
I think when many more
of these trials we've got
of drugs that are being studied,
we have, I think, 12 drugs
being studied right now,
you're gonna get a collection of drugs
that can enable you to reduce
the severity of this disease.
And also, medical practice
is learning so fast.
So that will hopefully give us some time.
Then, I expect the next
hopefully effective therapies
will be so-called antibody therapies.
So rather than having the immune
system generate a response,
you can provide patients who get COVID-19
with antibodies that can
hopefully target the virus.
A number of companies working on that.
And all of that, I hope, will,
and I believe, and maybe I'm an optimist
as a physician/scientist/drug developer,
that all of that will
help us really attenuate
and mitigate the overall
burden of this pandemic.
And that will buy us time
to hopefully get the right vaccine.
It is worth noting, I've
still yet to develop
a successful vaccine of HIV,
which is an ongoing pandemic
that started in the early 1980s.
There are many viruses
which I worked for years on,
to try to develop viruses
for something called RSV,
which causes a respiratory illness
around the world regularly.
Another virus called cytomegalovirus.
But there's a range of viruses
that we've been working on for decades
that we were never able to figure out
how to generate that
strong immune response
that we've been talking about.
And that's just a dose of
realism we have to live with.
And drug development
and vaccine development
is not a sure thing.
- Yeah, so the hope is the
vaccine might take a year,
might take 18 months,
it might take two years,
but hopefully we get more Remdesivirs,
or that steroid-type treatment,
or other things that make it less scary.
- Exactly.
- And this could
open things up.
I mean, when you look at
the general impact on the ecosystem,
I have this question from YouTube,
Ariana Kristoff-Dullis says,
"How do you think the pandemic
will affect the long-term future
of the pharmaceutical industry?
Do you think sharing
knowledge and science data
will be more open with in the industry?"
And I'll add, are there
just manufacturing things
that we're building
capacity to do in the future
that we'll just have
a more rapid response?
How are you thinking about
that, or what are you seeing?
- Yeah, I think so, so two
parts to that question.
I think right now that
the level of collaboration
has been unprecedented.
I co-chair an effort with Bill Gates
and the Gates Foundation
called the Gates COVID Accelerator.
There, we have 15 CEOs
really sharing compounds,
potential drug libraries,
sharing manufacturing capacity.
There's two other big
collaborations also running,
one run by the National
Institutes of Health,
another informal collaboration.
So there's been a pretty remarkable
amount of collaboration in the industry.
And I think what we're learning from this
is there are areas in what we call
the so-called pre-competitive space
that I think can be a really
powerful way to accelerate,
maybe in the future,
discoveries for cancer,
or heart disease, where
if there's something like,
for instance, one of the
things we collaborate on
is how do you get a good
animal assay for COVID?
So that you know a drug
might work in COVID?
This sounds obvious, but
it's really complicated.
And the more we can share our knowledge,
then the more we can-
- And explain what that is,
what is an animal assay?
- So, what we wanna do, is
before we go into humans,
we wanna figure out is a
drug active against COVID-19.
So we have to take cells
from an animal or human,
depending on what works best,
and we infect it with COVID,
and we try to treat
the cells with the drug
to see if the drug is active.
It turns out you can get lots
of false positives with this,
and how translatable is this into humans?
And it seems like such a simple thing,
but we've seen amazing
amounts of complexity,
which then could lead you
to spend a lot of time
on drugs that probably don't
make sense to spend time on,
or chase drugs that
should have been killed
in the development process.
So that's one example, a simple example,
of where we're learning we
need to collaborate much more,
manufacturing capacity is another.
So there's a lot of ways, I think,
we're learning we can collaborate.
Now I think for future pandemics,
which I think was part of the question,
I had opportunity to
lead Novartis's response
to the 2009 swine flu pandemic.
There, Novartis developed
vaccines back then,
we developed four vaccines
within six months,
but that was influenza,
and as I mentioned, we would
leverage existing technologies.
And we were able to produce, I think,
over 500 million doses
of vaccines and adjutants
for the world very quickly.
And it's interesting, we know
what's required, I think,
to really manage pandemics.
First, there's a series of
locations around the world,
which are well-understood,
where we know animals and humans interact,
and there's the possibility for viruses
to move to animals and humans.
They're called zoonotic
hotspots, they're well-mapped,
and we can really do
surveillance on these sites
if we make the relevant investment.
Then we need to have a lot of transparency
to rapidly know when something
has jumped into humans
so that we don't lose time.
Then we need two other things,
we need warm capacity, we call it warm,
it's a ready capacity for
vaccine and drug production
that could be rapidly scaled up.
That's one of the challenges right now
is we're trying to find
enough manufacturing capacity.
And we need public health systems
that are prepared for these kind of
very rare high-risk events.
And that's hard, you have to store
personal protective
equipment, and other things,
for something that may never come.
But when it does come, you're ready,
you have stockpiles ready,
and you can rapidly deploy them.
These were the findings,
I think, after SARS,
these were the findings after swine flu,
I suspect these will be the findings
after this next pandemic.
- That's super-valuable, and you know,
when we're having these
interesting conversations,
I completely lose track of time.
I realized we're already out of time.
Any finishing thoughts?
There's a bunch of
questions about young people
who are interested in
career tracks, you know,
entering into the pharmaceutical industry.
Obviously you all's
support for Khan Academy
is in that spirit of how do we have
more people be able to enter
this clearly very important
industry in the world?
Any finishing advice for young people
thinking about careers in
pharmaceuticals or biotech?
- Yeah, I think the
future in our industry,
like many industries,
is gonna be continuing to marry
different sectors together.
So, I think drug discovery today
is not gonna be what drug
discovery is tomorrow.
I would encourage all of
the students listening
to learn how to marry data
science and technology
with biology and chemistry,
because so much now of our work
is shifting in that direction,
how can you leverage technology
to really speed up a lot of these efforts.
I would say, build up,
also, as I said before,
your range of understanding
across different disciplines,
because you don't know where
the world will take you.
I never wanted to be a
CEO, but yet, here I am.
And so, I think, building
range in yourself can help,
and that includes, I
mean, I'm a big believer
in books and philosophy,
so I think all of those
things can really matter.
And then maybe, my last comment,
Sal, I just wanted to add,
is I believe in this moment in time
where we wanna build a more equal society,
where we tackle topics like
structural inequalities
and the problem of race
in the United States,
I think Khan Academy has
a remarkable role to play.
We know, fundamentally,
the educational system can be empowered
by great technology like Khan Academy.
So, I learned that,
I read a book called "Savage
Inequalities" in 1994,
talking about the inequities
in educational systems
of the United States,
and I firmly believe Khan
Academy helps tackle that,
so we're proud to be a supporter,
and look forward to the collaboration.
- Oh, appreciate that,
and obviously, we agree.
Well, Vas, thanks so
much for taking time out.
I'm sure, I can only
imagine how busy you are,
so this really means a lot.
Thank you for your support, and really,
why aren't you on the news channels
explaining about vaccines?
Because I feel like we're not
getting that level of depth,
so someone needs to give you
a call, if you have the time.
- Yeah, maybe, maybe.
I think maybe I'm too realistic.
- Maybe you're saying things
they don't wanna hear.
Well, thanks so much, Vas,
and I hope we get a
chance to do this again.
This was a real treat.
- Absolutely, take care, Sal,
and thank you everyone for listening.
- Thank you.
Well, everyone, well,
yesterday someone asked
what do I learn from these live streams,
or what have I learned?
I think that was just another good example
where, on a book level,
and obviously I've taught on Khan Academy
things about immunology, and antibodies,
and T-cells, but just talking to someone
who's a real practitioner in the field,
who's worked on vaccines,
who runs one of the largest
pharmaceutical companies
in the world, you know,
you just learned a whole new level
of what's going on in the world.
So hopefully you enjoyed
that as much as I did.
There's some things to ponder,
if this whole pandemic
goes a little bit longer
than we might have expected,
but hopefully you enjoyed that,
and I look forward to,
I'm not sure if we're doing
it tomorrow or the day after,
I need to look at my schedule.
I live my life hour-to-hour.
But I will see you all later
this week, at the homeroom.
See you soon.
Stay safe and healthy.